pour qu'il y racisme il faut qu'il y ait
un groupe humain
qui soit en position de faiblesse soit
parce qu'il est minoritaire soit parce
qu'il est économiquement
défavorisé soit parce que pour une
raison quelconque il est politiquement
écrasé en réalité vous pouvez si vous
avez un ennemi fort vous le détestez
vous êtes agressif mais on peut pas dire
qu'il y a racisme dans ce cas là est-ce
que vous voulez dire que la faiblesse
attire les coups la faiblesse attire les
coups à discutablement est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il y a un moment un seuil à
partir duquel le racisme devient un
danger ou un fléau tant pour les
victimes que pour les racistes je crois
que c'est le racisme est dangereux
d'emblée
et sans vous ou commence le racisme le
racisme commence à notre porte
j'ai pensé en lisant les
certaines œuvres enfantines du début du
19e siècle par exemple Bécassine que
c'était du racisme à l'état la petite
bonne bretonne il est très difficile de
dire qu'elle est d'une race différente
que les Parisiens qui se moquent d'elle
mais c'est tout de même il suffirait
très peu de choses pour que pour que ça
devienne du racisme le bougnat le
bougnat c'est tout de même quelqu'un
d'une Bounia auvergnat c'est quelqu'un
d'une catégorie différente alors le
temps a passé à l'heure actuelle
l'élargissement de la terre fait que le
racisme s'élargit à de plus grandes
surfaces mais le racisme c'est ça ça se
gonfle et ça se dégonfle c'est une
passion c'est une passion aveugle
et à votre avis c'est encore un fléau en
70 c'est un fléau absolument
actuellement j'espère d'ailleurs tout de
même que dans une époque
qui ne sait pas trop éloignée on finira
par se rendre compte que c'est à la fois
très absurde et très dangereux et que
l'humanité qui a tout de même donné la
preuve depuis qu'elle existe qu'elle est
coriace sera lutter contre ses propres
poisons vous voulez dire que l'humanité
aura suffisamment d'insta de formation
pour résorber le racisme
serait à l'instinct de mort le racisme
est un instinct pour celui contre lequel
on exerce et pour celui qui l'exerce
[Musique]